all right this morning we are focusing
on the question is there anything wrong
with being average we're looking for
answers in our continuing series with
Ted ideas that matter as students
prepare to go back to school in her
popular TED talk educator Danielle Moss
says that average students and employees
deserve more attention and recognition
they're the kids we think we can ignore
because their needs for support don't
seem particularly urgent they're the
co-workers who actually keep the engines
of our organization's running but who
aren't seen as the innovators who drive
excellence in many ways we overlook the
folks in the middle because they don't
keep us up awake at night wondering what
crazy thing they're gonna come up with
next Danielle Moss is the CEO of Oliver
scholars which helps black and Latino
students from underserved communities
prepare for college use with us now good
morning so you call this the Forgotten
middle the average workers and students
explain exactly what that means I think
in my career as an educator I saw lots
of focus on the highest performing
students and a level of high
accountability for how well the lowest
performing students did or didn't do
right and but most students are kind of
in the middle right and so there aren't
a lot of targeted resources or attention
paid to the vast majority of our kids
and we're missing out on something that
we're definitely missing out on some
yeah and your Tech Talk you said there
are some unclaimed winning lottery
tickets there in the middle absolutely I
think there's a lot of potential
sometimes kids just need to be exposed
and ignited you could you can't aspire
to do something that you've never heard
of right and so we have to kind of
figure out how can we expose kids give
them opportunities and get them excited
about learning again and how big was it
in terms of having someone in your life
to say you are capable of achieving more
because you said you sort of hung out in
that average space as a middle school
student but your mom stepped in and said
I expect more of you you can achieve
more how important
to have that I mean I think it was
absolutely transformational for me so
for the first half of my middle school
career I was pretty average 65 75 %
grades but my mother knew that I was
capable of a lot more and so one summer
much to my dismay she had me go to
summer school and I said but I'm not
failing and she said but you're also not
reaching your potential and it was in
that space that I really reconnected
with my academic aspirations and got
excited about learning again and had the
opportunity to just connect with
teachers I think in a way that we
sometimes don't get to do during the
school year so it's important to ask for
more some of those people in the middle
are people who don't necessarily excel
in school but maybe and other things
absolutely and so I think college access
is important but it doesn't mean college
only yeah right and so we have an
obligation to at least give all of our
kids the respect of saying I think
something more is possible for you and
we don't always get to right the end of
their stories but definitely I think in
some communities we don't we're not
concerned about whether or not we're
setting high expectations and high
income communities but in low-income
communities we kind of sometimes resign
ourselves to the circumstances that our
kids find themselves and you even had
just a basic question shift that could
help students achieve or at least reach
higher goals when it comes to college
right and so I took the question of you
know do you want to go to college too
what college would you like to attend
nobody in my family ever asked me if I
wanted to go to college right it was
kind of an assumed expectation and so I
always had that at the back of my mind
as something that was expected of me in
my household yeah and that certainly
shifts the narrative for students in
setting those high expectations but what
about the ones that are in the middle
and that stay in the middle is there
something wrong with being average I
don't think there's anything wrong with
being average I think we all have
average moments in our lives mostly
average moments
not you Anthony that's this table but I
think you know there have been times in
my career when my role as a mother or my
commitment to my family took first place
and so maybe your career takes a
backseat we have to get comfortable with
that we're really tuned into like sound
bites and glitz and glamour and
excellence but it's hard to kind of
maintain yourself at that level 24/7 and
everything you do so what do you add
this is an interesting point because if
a kid perceives themselves to add to be
average and you ask more there's a
challenge there that can sometimes you
can push a kid too hard I guess is what
I'm saying so I'm not sure if I'm sold
on but I think again I think you know we
owe our kids the opportunity you know
the respect of saying I think something
more is possible even if they don't
react in the moment you know I've had
the opportunity of staying in touch with
students that I taught in the early 90s
yes they don't get it all always when
you want them to get it have them come
back 15 20 years later and say you know
what you were on to something and I
eventually got that degree I eventually
got a graduate degree I just wasn't
ready at that point in my life I'm gonna
use a cheesy Casey Kasem line keep your
feet on the ground and keep reaching for
the stars there's nothing wrong with
that Danielle Moss thank you very much
thank you so much